I must interrupt you at this point to
bring up another very important issue
that happened this week Rupert Murdoch
bought Harlequin books how many of ever
read a Harlequin book you know the
Harlequin really some people I would not
have guessed in our audience but you
know they look they sell a hundred
million a year Harlequin books they put
out a hundred and twenty titles a month
show something there that you know like
relentless reduction my secret fantasies
waiting went wanting what she can't have
okay so Rupert Murdoch and Fox News boy
I mean News Corp bought this and you
know he's the most conservative media
Baron in the world they took over the
Wall Street Journal it became even more
conservative there their comment was the
Harlequin name and rich heritage will be
preserved independently I don't think
they're conservative agenda is going to
get in the mix and I as exhibit a here
is the first book they're putting out
look it's called loves fair and balanced
desire would you like me to read a
little passage here from this guy I
think you will see that
is in this it was Rick okay
it was Rachel winter havens first year
at Metro general for-profit hospital she
was a home schooled virgin brain nurse
but under her icy exterior there was a
passion that burned like an under
protected embassy in Libya rachel was
engaged to dr. Dax ransom a widower
whose wife had died in the war on
Christmas
in the warm valley between rachel's
ample breasts a single bead of sweat
lingered but just due to normal hot
weather not significant time to fly I
got Dax's manhood strained at the thin
fabric of his Dockers growing ever and
ever larger like the deficit under Obama
he fumbled with the wrapper of a condom
until she stopped him
don't bother she smiled my body has a
way of shutting that whole thing really
closed
now drill baby drill
what Dax didn't know is that Rachel was
cheating on him with a Latino orderly
named Hector Hector was dark and full of
a powerful energy like clean coal they
both knew their love was our forbidden
one Rachel pressed her finger against
Hector's quivering lips Shh she said
don't speak until you learn to speak
English
Hector nodded and buried his face
between Rachel's legs and she wrote his
mustache for what seemed like an
eternity it's true she thought Mexicans
are willing to two jobs Americans would